hay momentos o circunstancias en la vida
que los vamos a llevar siempre la mente
han pasado más de 25 años y recuerdo
como si fuera hoy una reunión en las
casas de mis padres estaban dos hombres
mi padre y yo
mi padre un hombre
muy humilde
un agricultor de corazón quien no solo
me ha enseñado a hacer negocios sino
también me ha da una lección de vida
en sus señores nos ofrecían un contrato
de exportación
en la noche hicimos una reunión familiar
y recuerdo que uno de mis hermanos dijo
no eso es muy difícil cambio yo pensaba
y dije
si se puede exportar nos no sabían de lo
que estaba hablando pero sabía que a
partir de ese momento tenía una misión
en mi vida
exportar fue en el año 1992
y ahí cambio un proceso de mi vida un
proceso pura vida con un solo si se
puede
yo era una mujer vivía en una casa
humilde en una familia muy unida muy
trabajadora iba a la escuela y al
colegio público iba con todos los
compañeros a pie era una niña feliz y yo
sabía una cosa yo no quería ser ama de
casa yo quería salir a vender a negociar
a conocer gente conocer lugares una
experiencia de vida
conocía el campo y la agricultura porque
vengo de una familia de agricultores de
una zona rural de costa rica
una familia de lo cual me siento muy
orgullosa porque con la agricultura
hemos podido salir adelante y hemos
creado valor para cientos de familias
que trabajan con nosotros y también
producimos comida al mundo con mucho
amor y pasión
hoy esta empresa
tiene 27 años y es líder en la
exportación de mi país de yuca y de
chayote sidra como le dicen ustedes los
colombianos exportamos por semana 25
contenedores a eeuu puerto rico canadá 7
países de europa y muy próximo chino
[Aplausos]
en ese momento mi familia cuando dijimos
sí creo que no sabíamos qué significa
es decir exportar
me gusta el poder
me gusta el poder para transformar
me gusta el poder para poder cambiar mi
propia realidad me gusta el poder para
amar el poder para dar el poder para
cambiar el entorno en el cual puedo
tomar decisiones
me gusta el poder
de la tierra para poder producir
la agricultura se este o por miles de
años y tiene que seguir existiendo
porque es el que nos da de comer pero en
este momento está en peligro porque
tenemos muchos retos y mucha gente que
alimentar nacen 2 215 mil niños por día
y para el 2050 vamos a tener 9.6
millones de personas y hay muchos retos
por los cuales tenemos que trabajar y me
preocupa cambio climático
el 98% de las personas que sufren hambre
vienen de países en vías de desarrollo
como los nuestros ya es y los cambios
climáticos va a afectar a esas zonas
principalmente se los digo yo muy
difícil producir con inundaciones con
juego con incendios
otro de los grandes retos que me
preocupa es suelos infértiles la erosión
y la contaminación hace que cada vez
tengamos menos tierras fértiles para
producir
otro los problemas es la población
envejece y cada vez vamos a tener menos
personas para la tierra
y uno de los retos más irónicos que a
veces creemos que es por la por la
sobrepoblación pero no es porque
desperdiciamos la tercera parte de lo
que producimos por eso nosotros tenemos
que trabajar juntos en ver cómo
producimos mejor cómo almacenar cómo
distribuir y cómo ahorrar comida
porque tenemos una responsabilidad moral
con los que no tienen que comer
tenemos que trabajar en una inteligencia
agrícola desde la raíz por aquellas
nuevas generaciones tenemos que trabajar
juntos principalmente por ellos pero
también por las mujeres sus madres que
con muchos sacrificios sacan adelante
sus familias
esas mujeres son las heroínas de
nuestros tiempos son mujeres poderosas
que luchan con muchos retos en sus casas
para salir adelante
ella desde el campo cosecha en esperanza
yo igual que esas mujeres iniciación
recursos como cualquier pymes
no tienen tiempo no tienen recursos no
tienen motivación
siempre piensen si se puede
las excusas nos atrasan debemos ir en
busca de las oportunidades
en mi vida yo tuve un mentor
el cual es mi padre el cual no puedo
dejar de mencionar esta tarde un hombre
con grandes valores un hombre justo un
hombre que me ha enseñado que para
exportar me ha dado las bases sólidas
un hombre
que vivió las injusticias cuando trabajo
para otros y las transformó en valores
que le enseñó a su familia y no las
trasladó a los negocios y yo oí a
ministro con esos valores que me
enseñaron desde que estaba niña
administro las empresas de nuestra
familia tengo también el honor de
presidir una de las cámaras más
importantes de mi país y también
presidir las cámaras centroamericanas de
exportadores y eso lo hago con valores
que aprendí con bases sólidas de que era
niña
y hoy quiero compartir con ustedes esos
valores no puedo ser egoísta uno es un
valores es haga negocios que le permitan
dormir tranquila
es a la base fundamental porque tenemos
que tener la conciencia tranquila para
ver oportunidades que se nos presentan
otro valor adquirido no le robe a los
agricultores ellos son los que nos dan
al alimento y son los que perciben menor
valor por su trabajo
otro de los valores es pagarle al
gobierno al estado los impuestos a usted
no le importa que los que los políticos
se lo roban porque si usted le paga
usted tiene la capacidad moral para
exigirles pero si no les paga no tiene
capacidad ni para criticar ni para
exigirle al estado
uno de los valores con cual dijo a la
ministra las empresas garantías sociales
en costa rica es muy sólida la garantía
de los sociales las garantías sociales a
los empleados y nosotros en nuestra
empresa a los más de 750 empleos que
tenemos le damos todas las garantías
porque ellos son parte de nuestra
familia vivimos con ellos convivimos
todos los días
y otro muy muy importante de los valores
el compromiso social
nosotros estamos ubicados en lugares
donde hay muchas necesidades
y yo comparto con la frase que dice
stefano un empresario suizo no hay
empresas exitosas en sociedades
fracasadas por eso tenemos que ayudar a
los a la gente que está ahí a las nuevas
generaciones porque ocupamos esa mano de
obra si nosotros ayudamos a esa gente
ellos nos van a ayudar a cuidar nuestra
empresa
cuando estamos joven
había una mujer que me inspiraba me
inspiraba poder cuando estaba niña yo
quería ser como ella yo siempre decía
doña rosmery karski
fue la primera diputada en costa rica y
la primera que presidió la asamblea
legislativa primer poder de la república
ella me transmitió poder lo que más me
llamaba la atención de ella era su
belleza su inteligencia su vestir
y yo decía yo quiero ser como ella
cuando yo sea grande y para eso estoy
trabajando ya pertenezco al directorio
político de uno de los partidos
políticos más importantes de mi país
pero para llegar ahí sé que debo
prepararme prepararme profesionalmente
pero también personalmente
porque nosotros todos somos producto de
muchas personas que nos ayudan y
empoderan en el camino
vivo en una constante capacitación estoy
trabajando mucho liderazgo
empoderamiento trabajo de equipo pero
mucho inteligencia emocional me mantengo
durante toda mi vida en capacitación y
he decidido hacerlo hasta el hecho de mi
muerte
una pregunta cuánto invierten ustedes en
su capacitación personal
yo comparto una frase que probablemente
ustedes la conocen porque es de bernardo
toro un compatriota de usted es filósofo
y es una de las bases del liderazgo hay
que saber dar y pedir ayuda
me he puesto reglas en mi vida reglas
como no fallar no fallar me a mí misma
porque creo que algo muy importante que
es la credibilidad la credibilidad
nuestro apellido no podemos fallarle a
nuestra familia a nuestros amigos a
nuestro equipo de trabajo eso es lo que
nos mantiene en ser personas sólidas
personas con credibilidad se puede
fallar pero luego de esto hay que
aprender y corregir
no creen que mi vida todo esto ha sido
éxito y bonito no también he cometido
errores y quiero compartir los gustos
cuando decidí la primera carrera
estudiar profesional estudió una carrera
de moda cuando terminé mi carrera y fui
a buscar trabajo no era lo que yo quería
hacer me había equivocado
inmediatamente matriculé una segunda
carrera
cuando estoy finalizando mi segunda
carrera quedé embarazada
soltera joven sentí un susto sentí miedo
sentí que mi vida se había paralizado mi
proceso lo que yo quería hacer pero
cuando ese niño nació más bien me dio
más ganas porque tenía un bebé por quién
vivir y en siempre pensaba si se puede
en la empresa también hemos tenido
proyectos sumamente exitosos pero
también proyectos fallidos y uno eso lo
lidere yo con mucho amor y pasión
sacamos al mercado una caja que se
llamaba críticos eran unas sus muelas de
5 tubérculos deliciosas súper naturales
llame camote yuca malanga blanca malanga
lila venía en las cajas azul color una
caja bellísima la idea era colocada al
mar que colocarlo mercado nacional y
posteriormente exportarlo
todos un éxito tres años después la
junta directiva deciden sacar el
producto al mercado porque no daban los
números números positivos rentables
sentí un dolor
un dolor sacar el producto pero la
ganadora fui yo porque aprendí que había
cometido errores durante el proceso por
eso les digo se pueden equivocar pero
inmediatamente hay que corregir los
errores
para llegar acá
debo decirles que he trabajado mucho
mantener un equilibrio entre cuerpo
mente y espíritu y yo a todos ustedes
las invito hoy para que todos los días
respiren profundo
mediten vivan su proceso de evolución
creyéndosela trabajando duro para
lograrlo porque si se puede las
oportunidades aparecen una vez en la
vida hay que tomarlas
les cuento
que nosotros tenemos que trabajar eso sí
para tener éxito unidas
tenemos que trabajar con más iniciativa
y tenemos que trabajar con más
inspiración
porque es más difícil caminar en tacones
lo bueno es que nos vemos mejor cuando
cumplimos las metas
y eso es cierto
[Aplausos]
y hoy quise contarles la historia de mi
vida para que ustedes puedan exportar
sus sueños exportar sus anhelos exportar
sus productos exportar sus servicios
quiero que ustedes vivan su proceso de
metamorfosis para que lleguen a
convertirse mujeres mariposas mujeres
que vuelan alto cual que puedan cumplir
sus sueños
gracias
[Aplausos]
y hoy lo que les doy es un ejemplo de
una niña que nació en una zona rural
con una ambición y pasión por la vida y
con las mismas oportunidades de todas
ustedes
y hoy me mantengo con el miembro
espíritu de esa niña me sigue levantando
pensando una frase que por favor quiero
que repitan después de mí si se puede
vamos si se puede vamos a vencer está
padre
gracias colombia
[Aplausos]